Okay, welcome everybody to another holistic health
power. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters. We have
a number of questions to go over. You sent your questions in and if you're
haven't and you're watching this you can feel free to
chat your questions in. I can get to that as well.
And we'll be able to look at those and get your questions
answered. Your questions that Laura said didn't let's get started with those.
Okay, first question. First of all, is there specific hormonal support
for somebody on their monthly cycles but has heavy cycles?
So hormonal support with somebody with heavy cycles.
You want to look at, first of all, anybody's having any type of
hormonal issues. It's best to get tested. So doing a Dutch test, which is a
dried urine hormone test, is the best approach
to get your all your estrogen or progesterone testosterone
numbers checked because there's all these intermediate metabolites that you
want to look at. If you're having issues with cycles, if
you're having issues with getting pregnant, if you're having any type of
hormone, if anything you think that is hormonally based,
I'm not talking about your thyroid because that should be a separate test.
But the Dutch test is the way to go. Getting a Dutch test
to look at the balance of all those intermediate
estrogens and progesterones and androgens and the Dutch test also gives you
an adrenal cortisol profile. That's the thing to get checked first.
So before you go into manipulating your hormones that are being careful,
anything that you take that's hormonally driven, it isn't just supporting
like a nutrition that's supporting the glands. If you're doing something that
is hormonal in itself, all your hormones work on a negative feedback loop. So if
you're taking DHEA, that works on a negative feedback loop, but that will basically
shut down production of DHEA in the adrenal glands. It's a common
supplement that's out there that's used by a lot of practitioners, people with a
adrenal fatigue, but you got to be careful taking that because that will shut
down your adrenal glands. So the best thing to do, whatever you're having
any hormonal issues, is get tested. Thyroid tests, so your thyroid doesn't
specifically control your estrogen and progesterone.
It's a good idea to get that checked on everybody on a regular basis anyhow.
So if you're in one of our courses, do our complete wellness panel, that gives you
a complete bit of olive profile and a complete um,
CBC with differential. Some other things that I like to look at
that can point to different health patterns and it gives you a complete
thyroid profile. So a complete thyroid profile, remember, is not just your TSH,
T3 and T4, it's T3, T4, 3, T3, T3, T4, Reverse, T3, TSH,
Thyro-globulin antibodies and TPO antibodies. So you want to look at that
whole big picture, would you look at your thyroid? Next question we had.
Hi Dr. Cutters, do you have experience in how to treat non-bellenoma
skin cancers? My husband and I both have skin cancer issues
of different parts of our bodies such as her face, scalp, legs,
arms, backs, and shoulders. We often use essential oils,
caster oil, lukewarm solution which is an iodide, heavy used
lights, eggplant cream, B17 cream. Are you feeling with using
mentally blue with red light therapy? And with the right
machine health, we have one that's different to the 165 model,
it's not a true right machine. But I have not tried it yet for skin cancer. Any
idea if this would possibly help? Any recommendation of supplements,
we had some experience with getting some of the skin cancers
burned out or cut, we prefer to do something not invasive at home treatment.
Thank you, dear Dr. Cutters. Long question. So there's
three main types of skin cancer. Melodoma is the most serious
that can be metastasized, that can be deadly. Melodoma is it something that
necessarily want to play with, who want to make sure you get that looked at by a
professional? I've also got a big fan of getting melanoma cut out,
still treated it. Topically, it seems to be the best method.
So help prevent metastasis. The other two types are basal cell and
squamous cell. So obviously, I'm just I'm just observing
99% chance we'll talk about with this question is squamous cell.
So squamous cell is or excuse me, basal cell. Squamous cell can be
just as dangerous and just as deadly and typically you're not going to get all
these spots all over your body. Where you're going to get all the spots all
over your body is with basal cell. Now some people are
so to have the husband and wife both have multiple basal cell
cancers is concerning a little bit because some people can genetically be
more predisposed to having more basal cell cancers.
What are the cause of basal cell cancers? So a lot of times
you'll see in the literature that the sun is blamed for skin cancer in general.
That is only partially true where the sun comes into play is if you're getting
your skin burns on a regular basis. Let's say you live or you travel to Florida
and you spend your days out in the sun all the time and you're getting
you know really very very tan. You can be getting these microbirds to your
skin and those any danger to the skin where you're killing skills skin cells
you can actually you know damage some cells so you're not actually killing
them. You're damaging them that could damage the DNA cause
rapid replication into a basal cell so that could cause a squamous cell that could
cause a melanoma. So it's burning damaged skin so it's not
sudden that causes skin cancer but it's being
getting burns sun burns so the sun can cause it if you're allowing yourself to
get burns. Also when a person is using
you know over the counters sun tan lotion that is full of chemicals. Those are known
to be cancerous causing chemicals so I'm not favorite of those. Make sure you
use a natural a sun protective if you're out of the
sun and you have issues with basal cell but my concern is that you two people
in the family that are not genetically related a husband and wife that are not
genetically related and they're both getting
you know numerous basal cell tumors. First of all my first
question would be do you know beyond the shadow of doubt that these are
basal cell tumors because you could have skin
discolorations that are not basal cell cancers. So a basal cell
cancer you could google what a picture would look like. Typically it's going to be
a little shiny. It's fairly easy to diagnose a basal cell versus
possible squabous cell or melanoma looks very different.
So if if you've said you know I've been to a dermatologist they've diagnosed
this is basal cell the ones we've had cut off we've had pathology reports
and they're basal cell. If you're getting multiple basal cell cancers
from two people in the family that are not genetically related
by concern would be other things that you're exposed to because you know
again causes of skin cancer can be burns skin burns
but also causes skin cancer can have an an inside out
cause to them too. So are there you know is it a water source that both people
in the family that are exposed to are you exposed to heavy metals
are you exposed to mycotoxins? Getting some of those tests done
would be wise you know instead of just constantly treating the cancer you're
digging to the reason why that this might be occurring
and figuring that out might be of help to you. So I would suggest
that you that you investigate that. Short of that what are some other alternative
treatments for basal cell? I think you labeled most of them here.
These are things that we have done in the past you could put cast oil.
We have not done Lugol's solution which is an iodine but that is a possibility.
The eggplant cream is a is a topical cream but I think you could still buy an
Amazon I think it's I think it's made in Australia or something like that.
I've played with that a little bit in the past. B17 cream we sell that that's
a good product that can be beneficial. Using um I've had people use
essential oils especially a regular oil on it on basal cells and that has
helped with a number of people. We have a curcumin cream for our patients which
is just a cream with with turmeric in it and then I think we do some blood
rooted in it. I remember what else we have in that
curcumin cream. We mix that up for patients that they've done that on basal cell
tumors. To have them surgically excised does not
cause you know any negative effects because basal cell typically
typically is not going to be tasteless. It's not you're not going to have to worry
about a systemic basal cell cancer. So it's I don't have the issues with that.
Of course it does want to have them surgically excise. Of course you got them on
your face and things like that it's not always pleasant.
The more appropriate as far as not leaving scars
it's with surgery goes. So if you can do a topical solution out of the better.
Again my big thing would be digging to the reason why
and doing some investigation through maybe some running some labs where the
microtox test run glyphosate tests on each one of you. Those would be common
causes, common pictures run heavy metal tests. They're not the greatest.
It's not the easiest thing to test, not as accurate as some of the other things.
Just to look at see if there's a familial cause. So remember there can be a
hereditary issue in a person's health and then there can be a familial
issue. Everybody in the family is sick. Well is everybody in the family sick
because of your genes? Well most likely not. But is everybody in your family sick
because you're all drinking the same water you're all eating the same food you're
all living in the same moldy house. You know it's it's familial
issues that are causing your problems. You need exposure to the same
poisons, toxins, foods, whatever it is. So you want to investigate that a little bit.
Okay, next question. I think it might curse you're over here.
What's what's the difference between Ivermectin and Venvenazole?
I've been using Venvenazole. I want to try Ivermectin
also. So these are medications. So the Venvenazole
that is typically used. So I can't make a lot of comments on this. I think this
person is talking about cancer. So there is a Venvenazole treatment for cancer.
There is an Ivermectin treatment for cancer. There's documented
evidence that these things can be beneficial for somebody with cancer. So
I can't make a lot of comments on those that because this is a medication.
But I can encourage you to give them a try. These are
medications that have been out for decades and decades and decades without
giving you know very few side effects. So it's not something that
would endanger anybody to take this thing. Typically that recommended
dosage for cancer with Venvenazole is the same dosage as you can give a 10 pound
dog. If Venazole is a typically a dog
dewormer cat dewormer. So it's an anti parasitic
medication. It could be purchased over the counter.
And the dosage that's typically recommended is what's given for a small dog. So
there's no danger in or harm in taking it. It's not necessarily a high enough
dosage that's going to take care of all a person's parasites if they have
parasites. They may want to use some natural things too. But if they're
taking it for cancer, you're not taking it for parasites. You're taking it for
cancer because it affects the cancer cell. I've rebecked it as well. It can be
used that way too. Next question is I don't know if it's a
cancer question or not. How often do I need to do coffee
enemies? Because we recommend a people that don't have cancer to do coffee
enemies. Certainly we recommend people that have cancer to do coffee
enemies. But it can be beneficial for people
with any type of chronic disease. So what's the benefit of doing coffee
enemies is really to simulate liver detox pathways.
So doing so by stimulating the parasympathetic nervous system.
So remember, your autonomic nervous system is your automatic nervous system
and it controls basically all your functions and everything in your
body. So all your organs are controlled by your autonomic
nervous system and you don't have to think about it. You don't have to think about
your liver, liver either, your kidney, kidney, you don't have to know what it
does, right? So those functions take place because
deep part of your brain, communicating through your
cranial nerves to your organs to tell those organs what to do. That's part of
your automatic or autonomic nervous system. If you have two parts of it,
your sympathetic, or you heard over your bite of flight mechanism,
and your parasympathetics, which are your call me to relax, you to detoxify
and your healing part of the autonomics and coffee enemies are
stimulating that part of the autonomics.
Curious whether I should be taking iron is the next question.
So whether a person should be taking iron or not really depends on their
complete blood count. So their CBC part of their blood test is how you
would determine whether a person should be taking iron or not.
So there are several different types of anemia.
One type of anemia is anemia where you have
deficiency, iron deficiency, anemia. And those people can be taking iron.
Now you have to take other things into consideration as well.
If on your CBC, you should have also requested on your CBC
that you also tested for ferritid. Now when ferritid is low, that can be a
side of deficiency as well. You would not treat the
ferritid low if your red blood cells were within normal limits.
But if your red blood cells are low, your RGW is high
and other signs of higher deficiency are there.
But if your ferritid is elevated, then you don't give iron.
So you have to treat it some other way, but you cannot. You don't want to give
iron if you have elevated ferritid. You know you have an inflammatory
process going on and you have to dig too bad.
However, just because you have anemia doesn't mean that you should go
it even if it's higher deficiency anemia. It doesn't mean you should go
and treat it with iron. Like anything, you need to dig to find out why do I have
anemia. So are you bleeding? Maybe it's just excess blood
from you have heavy periods. Well, you need to dig to why that is.
And solve that. You don't just treat things with supplements.
Nor should you just treat things with medication without figuring out why
in solving that answer to that Y first.
However, if you come to that decision and you're going to use iron
then you have to look at all those other factors.
Also, if you do have cancer, taking iron is an issue.
Can be an issue too, because iron can be gobbled up by cancer.
Because there is another type of anemia called anemia
chronic disease where stage four cancer patients will end up
showing anemia. And then you want to couple anemia with
artimisticid as well. So if the cancer is going to
couple the iron intake with artimisticid as well.
If the cancer is going to gobbled up the iron, you may
try to, artimisticid is an arm that tends to go
carry, be carried with iron. And it can be carried into the
cancer cell to help kill it. So that could be beneficial.
All right, thank you for joining. I think those are the only questions that we had
come in this week. Remember, you could go to our website and you could ask
questions in the box on the holistic health website.
Go to store our cutter's clinic website or hope for live
website. And you'll see the links to that holistic health
live website where you could ask questions and get your questions answered and
join us and see recordings of all our holistic
health power recordings that we've done.
And ask the questions that you could watch
for the answers later. All right, thanks so much.
Bye bye.